C'est ainsi que nous avons découvert
que nous devons mettre l'accent sur l'apprentissage et non l'école,
passer du fait de compter le nombre de corps dans la classe
au nombre de corps qui apprennent.
La seconde tâche était :
pouvons-nous y faire quelque chose ?
Pouvons-nous faire quelque chose quant à cette crise internationale
énorme, vaste, silencieuse et peut-être la plus négligée de toutes ?
Nous avons découvert que oui.
C'est génial.
Nous pouvons, pour la première fois,
avoir tous les enfants scolarisés et en apprentissage
en une génération.
Et il n'est pas nécessaire de réinventer la roue pour cela.
Nous devons apprendre des meilleurs de la classe,
mais pas n'importe lesquels,
les meilleurs de votre classe.
Nous avons considéré les pays selon leur niveau de revenus :
revenus faibles, revenus moyens, revenus élevés.
Nous avons considéré les 25% qui améliorent l'éducation le plus vite
et nous avons découvert
que si tous les pays progressaient au même rythme
que ceux qui vont le plus vite
dans leur niveau de revenus,
alors en une génération,
tous les enfants pourraient être scolarisés et en apprentissage.
Laissez-moi vous donner un exemple.
Prenons par exemple la Tunisie.
Nous ne disons pas à la Tunisie de progresser aussi vite que la Finlande.
Sans faire preuve d'irrespect.
Nous disons à la Tunisie
de considérer le Vietnam.
Ils dépensent des sommes similaires
pour les élèves de premier et second cycles
en termes de pourcentage du PIB par habitant
mais obtiennent de meilleurs résultats.
Le Vietnam a introduit une évaluation standardisée
pour l'alphabétisation et le calcul,
les enseignants vietnamiens sont mieux suivis
que dans les autres pays en développement
et les résultats des élèves sont rendus publics.
Cela se voit dans les résultats.
En 2015, pour PISA,
le Programme international pour le suivi des acquis des élèves,
le Vietnam a surpassé nombre d'économies riches,
y compris les États-Unis.
Si on n'est pas un expert de l'éducation,
on se demande : « Quoi de nouveau et différent ?
Tous les pays ne suivent-ils pas le progrès des élèves
et ne rendent-ils pas les résultats publics ? »
Non. Malheureusement, la réponse est non.
Nous en sommes très loin.
Seule la moitié des pays en développement
conduit systématiquement une évaluation de l'apprentissage en primaire
et encore moins en cycle secondaire.
Si nous ne savons pas
si les enfants apprennent,
comment les enseignants sont-ils censés se concentrer sur les résultats
et comment les pays sont-ils censés prioriser les dépenses dans l'éducation
pour obtenir des résultats
s'ils ignorent si les enfants apprennent ?
C'est pourquoi la grande transformation
avant d'investir
est de faire en sorte que le système éducatif fournisse des résultats.
Car verser plus d'argent dans des systèmes déficients
pourrait financer d'autres inefficacités.
Ce qui m'inquiète profondément --
si les enfants vont à l'école et n'apprennent pas,
cela dévalorise l'éducation
et les dépenses liées à l'éducation,
alors les gouvernements et les partis politiques disent :
« Nous dépensons tant d'argent pour l'éducation
mais les enfants n'apprennent pas.
Ils n'ont pas les bonnes compétences.
Nous devrions dépenser moins. »
Améliorer les systèmes éducatifs actuels pour qu'ils fournissent des résultats,
c'est important mais ce n'est pas suffisant.
Et les pays où nous n'avons pas assez d'enseignants qualifiés ?
Prenez la Somalie.
Si tous les élèves somaliens devenaient enseignants --
tous ceux finissant leurs études supérieures --
nous n'aurions pas assez d'enseignants.
Et les enfants dans les camps de réfugiés
ou dans les zones rurales reculées ?
Prenez Filipe par exemple.
Filipe vit dans l'une des milliers de communautés
installées le long des fleuves en Amazonas.
Son village compte 78 personnes et 20 familles.
Filipe et son camarade de classe
étaient les deux seuls à être en première en 2015.
L'Amazonas est un État au nord-ouest du Brésil.
Il fait 4,5 fois la taille de l'Allemagne
et est entièrement recouvert de jungle et de fleuves.
Il y a dix ans, Filipe et son camarade de classe
n'auraient eu que deux alternatives :
déménager à Manaus, la capitale, ou arrêter leurs études,
ce que la plupart faisaient.
En 2009 cependant, le Brésil a fait passer une nouvelle loi
faisant de l'éducation secondaire une garantie pour tous les Brésiliens
et obligeant tous les États à mettre cela en œuvre avant 2016.
Mais donner accès à une éducation de grande qualité,
à travers l'État d'Amazonas, cela est énorme et cher.
Comment avoir des enseignants de maths, de science et d'histoire
dans toutes ces communautés ?
Même si vous en trouvez assez,
beaucoup ne voudraient pas déménager là-bas.
Face à cette tâche impossible,
les fonctionnaires et les responsables publics
ont développé une créativité et un entrepreneuriat extraordinaires.
Leur solution : un centre multimédia.
Voici le fonctionnement.
Vous avez à Manaus des enseignants de contenu spécialisés et formés
donnant des cours en direct sur internet
à plus de mille salles de classe dans ces communautés dispersées.
Ces classes ont entre cinq et 25 élèves
et un enseignant généraliste accompagne la classe
pour l'apprentissage et le développement.
Ces 60 enseignants de contenu à Manaus
travaillent avec plus de 2 200 enseignants de tutorat dans ces communautés
pour adapter les plans de cours au contexte et à l'heure.
Pourquoi cette division
entre les enseignants de contenu et ceux de tutorat est-elle importante ?
Tout d'abord comme je l'ai dit, dans de nombreux pays,
nous n'avons pas assez d'enseignants qualifiés.
Deuxièmement, les enseignants font trop de choses
pour lesquelles ils n'ont pas de formation ou ne sont pas censés faire.
Considérons par exemple le Chili.
Au Chili, pour chaque médecin,
vous avez 4,5 personnes,
4,5 employés pour l'aider
et le Chili est dans la fourchette basse
car dans les pays en développement,
en moyenne, chaque médecin a l'aide de 10 personnes.
Un enseignant au Chili, cependant,
a moins d'une demie personne,
0,3 personne, pour l'aider.
Imaginez un service hospitalier avec 20, 40, 70 patients
et un docteur qui fait tout lui-même :
pas d'infirmiers, pas d'assistants médicaux,
personne d'autre.
Vous direz que cela est absurde et impossible,
mais c'est ce que font les enseignants tous les jours à travers le monde
avec des classes de 20, 40 ou 70 élèves.
Cette division entre enseignants de contenu et de tutorat est géniale
car elle change le paradigme de l'enseignant
afin que chacun fasse ce qu'il fait de mieux
et que les enfants ne soient pas juste scolarisés
mais aussi en apprentissage.
Certains de ces enseignants de contenu
sont devenus des enseignants célèbres.
Certains se sont présentés aux élections
et ils ont aidé à élever le statut de la profession
pour que plus d'élèves veuillent devenir enseignants.
Ce que j'aime à propos de cet exemple
va au-delà du changement du paradigme de l'enseignant.
Nous apprenons à tirer profit de la technologie pour l'apprentissage.
Le streaming est bidirectionnel
donc les élèves tels que Filipe peuvent aussi présenter des informations.
Nous savons que la technologie n'est pas toujours parfaite.
Les représentants publics estiment
qu'entre cinq et 15 pourcents des classes
seront hors ligne chaque jour
du fait des inondations, des antennes cassées ou de coupure d'internet.
Pourtant, Filipe fait partie des plus de 300 000 élèves
qui ont bénéficié du centre multimédia
et ont eu accès à une école après la primaire.
C'est un exemple vivant
du fait que la technologie n'est pas qu'un accessoire
mais peut être centrale à l'apprentissage et nous aider à amener l'école aux enfants
si nous ne pouvons pas amener les enfants à l'école.
Je vous entends déjà.
Vous allez dire :
« Comment allons-nous mettre cela en œuvre à travers le monde ? »
J'ai fait partie du gouvernement,
j'ai vu combien il est difficile de mettre en œuvre même les meilleures idées.
En tant que commission, nous avons lancé deux initiatives
pour faire de la génération de l'apprentissage une réalité.
La première est « l'initiative du pays pionnier ».
Plus de 20 pays d'Afrique et d'Asie
se sont engagés à faire de l'éducation leur priorité
et à transformer leur système éducatif pour qu'il fournisse des résultats.
Nous avons formé les dirigeants
à une méthodologie appelée « approche de prestation ».
Elle fait deux choses.
Durant la phase de planification, nous réunissons tout le monde --
enseignants, syndicats, associations des parents,
représentants gouvernementaux, ONG, tout le monde --
afin que la réforme et la solution que nous trouvons
soient partagées et soutenues par tout le monde.
Durant la deuxième phase,
on fait quelque chose de spécial.
C'est une concentration impitoyable sur le suivi.
Semaine par semaine, vous vérifiez
ce qui a été fait, ce qui était censé être fait
et parfois, nous envoyons quelqu'un physiquement dans le quartier ou à l'école
pour vérifier au lieu d'espérer que cela se soit passé.
Cela peut sembler être du bon sens,
mais ce n'est pas courant
et c'est pour cela que beaucoup de réformes échouent.
Cela a été testé en Tanzanie
et le taux de réussite des étudiants en second cycle
a augmenté de 50% en à peine plus de deux ans.
L'autre initiative pour que la génération de l'apprentissage soit une réalité
est le financement : qui va payer pour cela ?
Nous croyons et avançons
qu'un financement intérieur doit être la base
de l'investissement dans l'éducation.
Vous souvenez-vous que je vous ai parlé du Vietnam
surpassant les États-Unis pour PISA ?
Cela est dû à un meilleur système éducatif,
mais aussi à l'augmentation de l'investissement du Vietnam
passant de 7 à 20% du budget national en 20 ans.
Et si les pays veulent emprunter de l'argent pour l'éducation ?
Si vous vouliez emprunter de l'argent pour bâtir un pont ou une route,
c'est simple et évident,
mais pas pour l'éducation.
Il est plus simple de créer une belle image d'un pont
à montrer à tout le monde
qu'une image d'un esprit instruit.
C'est un engagement à plus long terme.
Nous avons trouvé une solution
pour aider les pays à échapper au piège du revenu moyen,
des pays qui ne sont pas ou plus assez pauvres, heureusement,
pour profiter de subventions ou de prêts sans intérêt
et pas assez riches
pour avoir des intérêts attractifs pour leurs prêts.
Nous réunissons de l'argent de donateurs
pour un mécanisme de financement de l'éducation
qui offrira plus de financement pour l'éducation.
Nous subventionnerons ou éliminerons complètement
les paiements d'intérêts pour les prêts
pour que les pays s'engageant à faire des réformes
puissent emprunter de l'argent,
réformer leur système éducatif et rembourser cet argent au fil du temps
tout en bénéficiant d'une population mieux instruite.
Cette solution a été reconnue
lors du dernier rassemblement du G20 en Allemagne
et l'éducation est enfin à l'agenda l'international.
Laissez-moi ramener cela à un niveau personnel
car c'est là que cela a une influence.
Sans cette décision d'investir le budget d'un jeune pays,
20% du budget d'un jeune pays dans l'éducation,
je n'aurais jamais pu aller à l'école,
encore moins en 2014
devenir ministre du gouvernement
qui a réussi à mettre un terme à la phase de transition.
Le prix Nobel de la paix attribué à la Tunisie en 2015
en tant que seule démocratie ayant émergé du Printemps arabe
est l'héritage de cette audacieuse décision de leadership.
L'éducation est la lutte pour les droits civils,
c'est la lutte pour les droits civils de notre génération.
Une éducation de qualité pour tous :
c'est le combat pour la liberté que nous devons gagner.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)